le marché ses odeurs ses couleurs une
sorte de refuge après quatre jours
d'excès ici le carême est dans tous les
esprits
les achats essentiellement composé de
feuillages et d'herbage pour général
entamé un jeûne ou gêner ses salades et
au pérou un petit coq aussi mais il faut
pas trop manger viennent et a le choix
pour les concours la papaye et tout je
sais pas dans son match
je vais pas mentir au carême je gêne pas
je mange normalement
pourquoi parce que normalement parce que
j'ai envie de manger normalement je vais
pas faire comme depuis pour crise est
comme ça vous avez de jeunes et oui
c'est beau temps c'est important oui
pourquoi pas trois pour asseoir dessus
une pratiquante et que ce soit on
représente le jeune pauvre mais si c'est
un sacrifice et puis ça me permet de
le prix est un peu un peu plus le jeune
qui se traduit par une privation de
nourriture fait partie intégrante de la
pratique de certaines religions au
presbytère de la cathédrale
les équipes du rosaire un mouvement
d'évangélisation catholique évoque le
sujet régulièrement avec les fidèles
j'allais justement je n'ai n'est pas
seulement particulièrement le boire et
le manger non le jeune c'est ce qui va
vous permettre de vous retirer de la
cigarette de du portable du portable
c'est important chez les chrétiens le
jeûne est une étape importante pour
nourrir sa foi il fait référence à un
épisode de la vie du christ durant
lequel il se priva de nourriture durant
40 jours quelques tué un jeune à est
plutôt centré sur ce qu'il a envie de
vivre avec dieu et donc c'est cette
relation le libère le libère de tout ce
qui est terrestre dans ce qui est du
monde et donc cette relation c'est ce
jeudi permet de d'entrer en communion
avec dieu et d'être plus en plus à même
de répondre à certaines questions de
prendre le temps de réfléchir par
exemple au delà de la dimension
spirituelle le jeune peut être
médicalement conseiller sauf que la
démarche existe des règles de
comportement respecter un jour le jeune
par semaine ya aucun problème
alors il faut qu'ils fassent un jour de
jaune toutes les semaines faut pas faire
moi je pense que c'est une erreur de
faire huit jours de jeûne en continu et
après
de reprendre les mauvaises habitudes
c'est aberrant si vous voulez d'un côté
de ce bas frères manger beaucoup et de
vivre n'importe comment
et puis à près de 10 rebonds je me
rachète une conduite pendant quinze
jours trois semaines puis on recommence
après il existe plusieurs formes de
jeunes qui sont généralement basés sur
la durée d'autres religions comme les
musulmans les bouddhistes ont également
leur période de jeûne dans la démarche
tous se retrouvent autour d'un point
commun qui d'autre que l'élévation de
l'esprit